ah the planet Earth our beautiful home
we'd like to believe it will be around
forever but what if it isn't aliens
comets weapons of mass destruction
black holes even the Sun could destroy
the earth so what's it gonna be how will
it affect you or your descendants and
would we be able to stop it this is what
if and here's what would happen if we
knew the time the earth will die in July
of 2019 we had an arrow miss with
asteroid 2019 okay its impact would have
been similar to a nuclear bomb and the
scariest thing scientists didn't see it
coming until it was too late
NASA would need a whole year's notice to
stop a doomsday collision how would they
do that they'd launch an object into
space to collide with the asteroid
destroying it before it got close to
Earth barring any more immediate dangers
will the earth still die what will it
look like in the near future and the
distant future what could we do to save
the earth
you know earth wasn't always the diverse
paradise we know it as in fact about 4
billion years ago it looked more like
something from a sci-fi movie
supervolcano's meteors and a toxic
atmosphere made our planet inhospitable
so how did it become today's earth well
it went through many geological
atmospheric and evolutionary steps in
fact homo sapiens
only came into the story about 200,000
years ago human life evolved during a
time when the climate was mild and
unstable enabling a vast diversity of
life something we take for granted today
we're already beginning to see the
effects of rapid changes to our climate
and the destruction it causes what will
the future look like if we continue down
this path how will it affect your
children the next hundred years we'll
see temperatures rise three degrees and
that may not seem like a lot but it is
enough to create droughts extreme
wildfires stronger hurricanes and food
shortages 200 years into the future the
world's population will reach 9 billion
hopefully we spend all that time between
now and then creating new technology to
offset the environmental destruction and
keep up with the demand for food in 300
years humanity will be considered a type
one civilization on the Kardashev scale
which means we use all the available
resources on our planet if only we could
get to type 2 and use the power of the
Sun or even type 3 which uses galactic
power
these are things that could affect your
direct descendants but let's jump even
further into the future when humans may
or may not even be around in 100,000
years from now the biggest star in the
Milky Way Canis Majoris will explode the
supernova will be visible from Earth in
pure daylight as this is going on 20
super volcanoes will spew out 417 cubic
kilometers of magma in all directions at
this point Earth will be starting to
resemble the planet we saw four billion
years ago
in 600 million years the Sun will begin
to burn up the earth as the Sun gets
hotter from its shrinking core the only
life left on earth 800 million years
into the future will once again be
single-celled organisms and 2.8 billion
years in the future the earth's
temperature will be a scorching 150
degrees there will be no life left on
earth
can we stop this slow demise into a
piece of lifeless Rock probably not in
fact our current actions might even be
speeding up the process instead we could
work towards prolonging this calm period
in Earth's history by protecting its
life-sustaining ecosystems and using
renewable resources the end of the earth
has captured many people's imaginations
there are even doomsday groups with
specific theories on how the end will
come some people believe that aliens
will show up and wipe us out maybe
because of our rich natural resources or
maybe they just won't like us other
people believe that we will be sucked
into a planet destroying black hole
caused by the Large Hadron Collider oh
and don't forget deathly gamma ray
bursts which can produce as much energy
in one millisecond as the Sun does in
its entire lifetime
but what about us can we destroy the
earth with weapons of mass destruction
luckily no we might be able to wipe
humanity out but to physically destroy
the earth is not possible the most
powerful explosive device detonated so
far is the Soviet built Tsar Bomba also
called big Ivan is a 50-megaton hydrogen
bomb detonated in 1961 in the Arctic was
over three thousand times more powerful
than the bomb that destroyed Hiroshima
yeah we'd need 1 quadrillion Tsar Bomba
to obliterate the earth in the long term
the earth will eventually die but
hopefully we can fend off any immediate
disasters and use that time to figure
out a way to continue our existence
through technological and biological
advances how would the human race react
to news that the earth like any living
organism is on its way to the great
beyond would it divide us or unify us
even though the earth will die
whether that's sooner or later we can
make it a better place while we're here
for now this is all we've got so let's
take better care of the environment and
maybe stay away from weapons of mass
destruction we don't want to risk a
world war 3 but that's a story for
another what if
[Music]